(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Inside this 250
ton three headed elephant
is a museum commissioned
as a place to preserve
Thai heritage.
(upbeat music)
The Erawan Museum is located
just outside of Bangkok.
It is named and inspired
by the mythological king
of elephants in Hindu mythology.
Inside there is a large temple
in the belly of the elephant.
And downstairs is a museum
which features carvings inspired
by Buddhism, Christianity, and Hinduism.
(upbeat music)
Outside a walk around the
landscaped paths feature model
elephants that trumpet as
guests walk under them.
(elephant trumpet)
With thousands of visitors
every year, the museum serves
as a tribute to Thailand's past.
(gentle music)